non
je fais tellement ça donne raison les
pilotes
toc toc toc
qui est là gérard gérard qui j'ai
rarement vu quelqu'un d'aussi magnifique
sais pas s'il n'est pas le technicien
mis au point en disant ok les gars du
coup dès 21h30 et on est toujours coincé
dans une grande roue à écouter mon
attention quand même pas grand chose
vous avez une coup une banale un jus de
fruits vins plaide pour deux n'ont pas
pu se bloquer genre à quoi à ceux qui
tombent ils dorment ceux qui sont reçus
je crois qu'il ya trois gamins puissent
déjà avec toi c'est pas un cadeau merci
super bon gars comme ça
donnait sur instagram et puis comme ça
je vous donne des news
on ne rentrait en deux jours deux jours
deux jours du 2 jours soir la police
ressenti manifestants 48 ans
je tâte de faire 3
km 47 minutes j'ai fait un bac es mais
je sais faire un problème de chypre 5
mon coeur est là l'embouteillage de vélo
qu'elle jette des vélos en bouteille je
me suis dit clame toi va boire un verre
j'ai pris un verre je parraine les
baltes et rassurer les voitures vous ne
vont pas dans ce bouquet toujours les
renouil
comment
le wake up 2 pb
à 0 1 comment
[Musique]
ok
alors au vu de l'actualité j'ai décidé
de refaire un titre à moi et de le
mettre au goût du jour ça ferait elle
aimerait qu'on l'a en bourse
mademoiselle valérie elle est vrai qu'on
leur ombre mais nous on ne veut pas non
non et les bricoleurs en bourse
mademoiselle ben ali elle aimerait qu'on
l'a montbourg ce mais elle elle ne veut
pas t'en penses quoi